Mes courriels auraient pu manquer de diplomatie.
Aurais-je été trop insistante dans mes messages vocaux ?
Howard détestait-il mon projet
ou bien étais-je trop sensible ?
Cela devait être moi.
Mais un jour,
je marchais dans un couloir et je croise Howard.
Il a une pile de documents en main.
Quand il me voit, son visage s'éclaire
et il me dit :
« Sara, Tom vient de m'envoyer ça, tu devrais y jeter un coup d'œil.
C'est un projet pour recruter davantage de femmes. »
(Rires)
« Tom a une super idée, je pense.
On doit l'encourager, à mon avis. »
Howard me tend alors mon propre projet.
Il m'explique les bénéfices de mes propres propos.
(Rires)
Howard n'a jamais été contre l'idée de recruter plus de femmes.
Mais il avait besoin qu'un homme lui dise
pourquoi c'est important de recruter davantage de femmes.
Et pendant toute cette scène,
je me suis tue.
Car je pressentais n'être finalement qu'une invitée
dans un lieu qui n'avait pas été conçu pour moi.
Alors, au lieu de remettre en question mon environnement,
je me suis remise en question.
Je voulais comprendre
pourquoi tant de femmes talentueuses travaillent tant d'heures,
démarrant leur carrière avec confiance,
pouvaient devenir formatées pour douter de soi et se convaincre :
« Ça doit être moi. »
Comment est-ce possible ?
La situation ne s'améliore-t-elle pas ?
Les chances ont augmenté pour les femmes ces 50 dernières années.
Mais la situation stagne depuis 10 ans.
Des experts avaient estimé
que l'écart salarial aura disparu en 2059.
Mais en septembre 2019,
les mêmes experts ont annoncé que, selon les données récentes,
ils avaient dû revoir leurs prévisions
pour 2119.
(Murmures dans le public)
Dans cent ans !
Au-delà de l'écart entre les salaires,
les femmes restent sous-représentées dans les directions,
elles ont moins facilement accès aux dirigeants seniors,
et elles s'éloignent des secteurs à forte croissance
comme les high-techs,
à un taux 45% plus élevé que les hommes
pour des raisons de culture, selon elles.
Que faisons-nous pour réagir contre l'inégalité des genres ?
Pourquoi nos efforts sont-ils infructueux ?
De nombreux secteurs pensent gérer le problème
car ils ont mis sur pied des formations.
Huit milliards de dollars sont dépensés en formation chaque année,
selon la Harvard Business Review.
Ces mêmes études concluent que ces formations n'ont pas d'effet,
voire qu'elles ont un effet négatif.
Des recherches portant sur le recrutement et les pratiques de promotion
dans 830 entreprises sur 30 ans
montrent que les hommes qui ont dû suivre de formations en diversité
ont tendance à se rebeller
en recrutant et promouvant moins de femmes
et moins de personnes issues des minorités.
L'autre solution consiste à demander aux femmes de changer leurs comportements.
De s'intégrer.
De forcer la porte.
De négocier aussi souvent que les hommes.
Et de suivre plus de formations.
Les femmes obtiennent la majorité des diplômes universitaires,
sont meilleures en leadership que leurs pairs masculins
et gèrent des entreprises qui font mieux que la concurrence.
Le problème ne semble pas être l'éducation,
ni les compétences, ni l'acuité en affaires.
On a déjà conquis tout ça.
Suffisamment pour avoir un impact sur les entreprises qui sont prêtes.
Mais ces approches oublient de se pencher sur un problème systémique crucial :
les biais inconscients.
(Applaudissements)
Nous nourrissons tous des biais, ce n'est pas grave en soi.
C'est localisé dans l'amygdale
et ils continuent d'agir quand nous allons travailler.
Les biais influencent si je vous apprécie ou pas,
ce que je vous crois capable de réaliser
et même le volume d'espace qu'il me semble que vous occupez.
Le mouvement Me Too, parmi d'autres,
a répandu une prise de conscience des biais de genre.
Mais ces histoires de harcèlement qui ont fait la une des journaux
ne sont qu'une facette.
Il n'est pas nécessaire de harceler une femme pour ruiner sa carrière.
Les messages que je reçois de femmes ne parlent pas de harcèlement.
Elles sont tolérées sur le lieu de travail.
Mais elles ne sont pas valorisées.
Je n'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un dire :
« Vous savez ce que j'aime chez mon employeur ?
Ils me tolèrent si bien,
je me sens tolérée. »
(Rires)
Pour dépasser l'inertie,
nous devons aller au-delà de Me Too.
Aller au-delà d'être tolérée en tant que femme.
Mon organisation a décidé de résoudre le problème de deux manières.
D'abord, si nous avons tous des biais,
il convient de structurer activement notre lieu de travail contre les biais,
pas en essayant de changer les esprits une formation à la fois.
Notre équipe a commencé par identifier plus de 100 leviers culturels
qui peuvent être ajustés pour contrer l'impact des biais.
On a découvert que de petits ajustements peuvent amener de grands changements.
Et ça coûte beaucoup moins que 8 milliards de dollars.
À quoi ressemble un petit ajustement ?
Quand on demande à une femme de mentionner son genre
avant de remplir le formulaire de candidature,
ou de répondre à un test de compétences,
ses performances sont moins bonnes que si on ne lui avait pas demandé son genre.
Dès lors, comment éviter activement ce biais de stéréotype ?
Déplacer la question de genre à la fin du formulaire.
Deuxième exemple.
Une étude nationale que nous avons menée
a révélé que les hommes étaient 50% plus susceptibles d'affirmer
qu'ils avaient passé plusieurs évaluations fréquentes
durant le cours de l'année.
Par opposition à une seule évaluation par an.
Cela importe.
Le magazine « Fortune » a passé en revue les évaluations par secteur industriel.
Il met en avant le fait que des critiques liées à la personnalité,
[ Calme-toi ! Tu es un peu agressive. Tu pourrais être plus chaleureuse.]
sans lien avec les compétences,
apparaissent dans 71 cas sur les 94 évaluations de femmes.
Sur les 83 évaluations d'hommes,
la critique personnelle apparaît deux fois.
Dans les entreprises qui mènent des évaluations plus courtes et fréquentes,
des évaluations hebdomadaires de cinq minutes, par exemple,
concentrées sur des projets spécifiques,
les critiques liées à la personnalité disparaissent.
L'écart perçu de performance entre les hommes et les femmes
est pratiquement inexistant.
Alors que les évaluations annuelles se basent sur des impressions générales,
une boîte de pétri pour cultiver les biais,
des évaluations courtes et concentrées sur des objectifs
éliminent les zones grises basées sur les impressions.
Certaines entreprises agissent concrètement
pour contrer les impacts des biais.
Mais d'autres sont juste bonnes pour en faire la publicité.
Nous avons donc voulu déterminer lesquelles agissent réellement.
On a créé une enquête sur Facebook
et demandé aux femmes dans des ateliers de discussion
comment elles choisissent un employeur qui les valoriserait.
La réponse la plus fréquente ?
« J'ai fait une recherche internet. »
C'est ce qu'on a fait aussi.
(Rires)
On a fait une recherche sur : « meilleur employeur pour les femmes dans les techs »
Nous avons obtenus trois listes très différentes.
Une entreprise en première position sur une liste
n'apparaît pas du tout sur une autre.
Certaines listes n'ont pas de critères,
et d'autres sont des publicités.
Elles sont payées pour ça.
Les employés et les employeurs recherchent des comparaisons neutres,
qui dépassent les bonnes intentions.
La certification LEED offre aux entreprises cette transparence
sur la gouvernance de l'environnement
en explicitant les étapes précises nécessaires pour obtenir la certification.
Nous souhaitons mettre à disposition des entreprises
un script semblable pour l'équité des genres.
Notre deuxième étape fut donc
de rassembler les connaissances générées par nos tests sur les leviers culturels
et de nous associer avec l'Université de Washington
pour fonder la première certification standard
pour l'équité des genres dans les entreprises américaines.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Pour créer ce standard,
nous avons dû déterminer ce qui est important et ce qui ne l'est pas.
Ce qui est important
n'est pas le pourcentage total de salariées femmes.
Ni le nombre de femmes au Comex.
Nous avons nommé cela la métrique de vanité.
On peut les acheter
alors que la culture interne resterait équivoque.
Les facteurs importants et qui doivent être mesurés
sont sous la surface.
Par exemple,
même dans les organisations où un pourcentage égal d'hommes et de femmes
disent avoir accès à un mentor,
ceux des hommes sont plus souvent dans des positions plus élevées.
La relecture de nos enquêtes montre
que les hommes sont deux fois plus susceptibles de dire
qu'ils ont reçu une opportunité de suivre une personne de la direction.
L'écart salarial nous est très familier
mas les écarts d'opportunités aveugles ont un impact aussi grand.
Quand on évalue la culture d'une organisation,
on mesure les écarts entre les expériences des hommes et des femmes.
Plus l'écart est petit,
plus l'équité est centrale dans cette culture.
Nous avons également cherché quels étaient les critères culturels
importants pour les hommes et ceux importants pour les femmes.
Trois facteurs récurrents importent aux hommes
et une dizaine aux femmes.
Un seul est commun aux deux.
En haut de la liste des femmes, on trouve :
les congés parentaux payés,
les soins de santé pour les personnes à charge
et l'impression que leurs idées sont écoutées
et qu'elles en reçoivent le crédit.
Il s'agit de quelques indicateurs parmi les 188 autres
qui déterminent si une organisation atteint ou pas
nos standards quantitatifs pour l'égalité dans le milieu du travail.
Sur la base de données significatives.
Ce sont les facteurs
qui créent une culture d'équité durable.
Pas pour un mois ou un trimestre,
pour des années.
Où en sommes-nous alors ?
On dit continuellement aux femmes dans la vie professionnelle
qu'elles peuvent devenir ce qu'elles souhaitent
et que cela dépend d'elles.
Les femmes de couleur,
qui subissent un écart salarial encore plus grand,
entendent cela aussi.
Les deux tiers des travailleurs au salaire mininum sont des femmes
et on leur dit cela aussi.
Les personnes qui ne s'identifient pas comme homme ou femme
et camouflent leur identité au travail aussi.
S'ils peuvent entendre qu'ils peuvent devenir ce qu'ils souhaitent,
que cela dépend d'eux,
je crois qu'il est temps que les entreprises entendent le même propos.
Éliminer les biais au travail n'est pas une mince affaire.
Mais nous ne pouvons plus nous permettre
de laisser la moitié de la population rester ignorée.
Nous avons créé un cadre de changement pour les entreprises.
Les entreprises peuvent devenir ce qu'elles souhaitent.
Cela dépend d'elles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)